KRISTEN: So with
that, I am going
to turn it off to our first
keynote speaker, Kris Clark.
She also works at Lincoln
Laboratory with me,
but in a completely
different field.
She's going to talk
about space cameras.
KRIS CLARK: So as Kristen
said-- I'm also Kristen,
but I go by Kris-- I work
at Lincoln Laboratory.
And I want to say that
this is an amazing program.
So first, how many of you have
ever done a program like this?
Like an engineering
kind of thing for girls.
Come on, way up.
I can't see that.
OK, cool.
Now, how many of
you are freshmen?
Sophomores?
Juniors?
Seniors?
All right, no seniors.
They're all busy doing
college applications.
All right, so let's get started.
So today, I'm going to
talk a little bit about me,
just because we're
kind of looking
at what makes an engineer.
It can be all over the map.
So there is no one key picture
of what an engineer looks like,
or what a scientist looks like.
Then we'll go into a little bit
about just really basic stuff,
like what is a camera?
What are the key
components of a camera?
And then what can cameras do?
And then specifically
I'm going to tell you
about the program I'm
currently working on.
It is a space camera
looking for as exoplanets.
So I'll tell you a little bit
about the specifics of that,
and I have some kind
of cool animation
that they did for me to
show you the orbit, and all
that sort of stuff.
So stop me, raise your hand.
Questions, you don't have to
wait till the end or anything.
So just speak up.
Raise your hand.
Get my attention.
So how I got here.
So you guys all know,
this is Massachusetts.
I did not stray very far.
I was born in Worcester in
the center of the state.
I moved to Billerica, Mass
when I was two with my family.
I went to Billerica
Memorial High School.
Then I went to MIT for
undergraduate, then to Tufts
for graduate school.
So it's kind of this circle.
I never went more than
50 miles from home.
And ended up at
Lincoln Laboratory.
I've been there for
the last 12 years
working on space-based
optical systems.
So I have three brothers.
Two of them are
also techie geeks.
One is a lawyer, so he's
kind of the odd man out.
But the only time really
that I left the country
was to be an exchange student
for a year in high school.
And other than that,
stayed very close to home.
So there's tons of opportunities
right in your own backyard
for being an engineer.
All right, so now I need
some audience participation.
What is a camera?
Anyone want to
take a stab at just
kind of a general
definition of a camera.
Or even just if you're not
really sure how to define it,
maybe just describe
what it does.
That's a good way to start.
AUDIENCE: A device
that takes photos.
KRIS CLARK: Good, good.
Device that take photos.
Anybody want to add to that?
Like a key piece
of information you
can think might
improve the definition
for if you needed to describe
a camera to somebody.
AUDIENCE: Light really affects
how the photos [INAUDIBLE].
KRIS CLARK: Light affects
how the photo is taken.
Is that what you said?
Yep, so light is very key.
That's pretty much what
we're trying to collect.
Anybody else want to
add to the definition?
Let's see, this is kind
of a generic definition.
A camera is an optical
instrument for recording
or capturing images.
So if you look at
that definition,
really there are
two basic components
you need to a camera.
Does anyone want to take a
guess at one or both of them?
What's the first thing
you have to do when
you want to take a picture?
All right, I'll
give you this one.
Somehow you have to
collect the light, right?
So focus your energy.
It can be visible light.
We'll talk a little bit more
about other types of energy.
But once you have that
light where you want it,
what's the next step?
It's there, but what do you
have to do to get a picture?
AUDIENCE: Have
something record it?
KRIS CLARK: Exactly.
So you need a detector.
So basically two components.
You want to get the light
for whatever you're trying
to image to a particular place.
And then you need some sort
of device-- old school,
if you're old school
like me, you've
seen film cameras before.
You took some of those apart.
So film was the detector.
Now, it's much more
the digital age.
You've got CCDs and all
sorts of digital imagers.
So those are basically
the two things
that you have to
do for a camera.
And then from there,
sky's the limit.
There are so many different
types that you can do.
So I thought I'd
start really simply.
Has Anyone ever heard
of a pinhole camera?
Anyone ever built
a pinhole camera?
All right, so what's
the basic premise?
Do you remember what the idea
is behind a pinhole camera?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you just put
like little holes in a box.
KRIS CLARK: Yep.
So you have-- let's see if
I can get my little pointer
thingy to work-- a tiny,
tiny hole in a dark box.
So there's not even a
lens in this camera.
But that tiny, tiny, tiny
hole is the first half
of what you need for a camera.
Something to collect the light.
Now the problem with a pinhole
camera, the tiny, tiny hole
can't collect much light.
But it does limit
very specifically
that light from a particular
point in what you're looking at
can only get to a very specific
point on the inside of the box.
And so basically, that's your
limiting light collection,
and the back surface of the
box is your image plane.
Now, you can't
really capture it,
because it's just
the back of a box.
But you can look at it, and it's
there if you want to see it.
So very, very primitive.
So if we get into some things
that you guys see every day,
and you probably don't
really think a whole lot
about how they work.
But who would have guessed
how many components
are in that little
tiny phone camera?
That's a lot of stuff.
There's like six
lenses before you even
get to your detector image.
So lots of lenses are used.
And we won't talk specifically
about lens design.
But basically, the
fancier cameras
have gotten-- you've noticed,
iPhone cameras always
tell you, now our image quality
is improved from iPhone 4
to iPhone 6 by whatever percent.
It's all about how well you can
correct the light that you're
trying to collect and
get it in the spot where
you want it to be.
And that takes more
and more lenses.
So that gets more sophisticated.
And then you have your
software for image processing.
So you can play
around, like when
you post-- I'm way too old
for this-- but on Instagram
and Twitter, you can
do it color filters
and make it look
kind of different.
That's all in the
image processing,
which you guys will get to do.
Now, I like the
eye as an example,
because you've been using this
camera since you were born.
And pretty much you have a lens.
It focuses the light on
the back of your eye, which
is called the retina.
That's your detector.
And then your brain
processes that information
from the retina.
So your brain really is the
image processing software.
And I don't know if
you guys knew this,
but if we go back
to-- what do you
notice about the image of the
tree in the pinhole camera?
It's upside down, right.
When your eye lens focuses
on the back your retina,
the image is actually
inverted as well.
Your brain fixes that for you.
So this is kind
of a funny thing,
like you're looking at it.
Your lens actually
focuses it upside down,
but your brain knows
that up and down.
So kind of an interesting
built in image processing.
So can you guys think of any
other examples of cameras
that you use kind of everyday?
Or maybe not every
day, just specific ones
you've heard of maybe
for other applications.
You see a camera somewhere else
that you go during the day.
Or let's see--
AUDIENCE: I guess a
camera for medical use,
like for surgery so they
can see what's inside.
KRIS CLARK: Yes, exactly.
You guys are going to hear about
a really cool medical imaging
camera at lunchtime,
I think one that
detects tumors in patients.
So very good example.
Anybody got another
different example
of what cameras are used for?
AUDIENCE: Infrared cameras.
KRIS CLARK: Yep,
infrared cameras.
What do those do?
Exactly.
And that brings us
to our next portion.
So when we talk about light, is
anyone familiar with the term
electromagnetic spectrum.
You know what that means?
Can you describe
it a little bit?
AUDIENCE: It's the frequency--
it's the different scale
for the light [INAUDIBLE].
KRIS CLARK: Exactly right.
So most of the time
when you say light,
you think of visible
light, right?
What we can see.
But really, the
electromagnetic spectrum
defines a really large range
of basically electromagnetic
waves.
And this very small
region-- and we kind of
define this by
wavelength, how long
is the wavelength of the light?
Most of the stuff we work with
is in this very small spectrum.
But it branches all the way
out here to radio frequencies,
where a wavelength is
the size of a building,
all the way out to like gamma
rays, where a wavelength is
like atomic size.
So the big reason probably that
we focus so much on visible,
that's where our eyes work.
That's where we learned
everything from the ground
up of how imaging works,
because we didn't have CCDs.
We didn't have film
a long time ago.
We only had eyes and
what we could see.
But now there are
cameras available,
like you said, in infrared.
And I have a little
picture of that.
Take a picture of your dog.
So basically it's a
different type of camera.
It's collecting infrared light,
which your eyes cannot see,
but the particular lenses that
are used to focus this light
are specific materials that
are used to focus infrared
wavelengths.
And the detector is sensitive
to that range of wavelength
as well.
So when we say we need
a lens and a detector,
it's important to realize
that the materials that
go into those are very
specific to whatever
part of the spectrum
you're trying to image.
So there's an awful
lot that goes into it.
Some people spend their entire
career on visible systems.
Some people work
entirely in the infrared.
There are whole companies--
FLIR System is all about looking
for infrared.
So their whole business is
built on infrared cameras.
Certainly medical
imaging, right?
You've got x-rays.
So there's tons of
fields, and they
can be very specific about
what range they're looking at.
So I threw out some
other examples.
Some of them you
guys already hit on.
So here's a little tiny camera
that you can actually swallow.
And people can image things
in your digestive tract.
It's a little bit creepy to
think about, but it works.
Certainly if you've been to
the airport anytime recently,
Homeland Security,
cameras everywhere.
Does anybody know, there's
a specific kind of software
that they can use with
cameras in the airport.
They can do something
very specific
if you're looking for
a particular person.
AUDIENCE: Face recognition?
KRIS CLARK: Face
recognition, right.
So that's part of the image
processing side of things.
There are cameras
very sophisticated
that can scan whole crowds.
And based on a still image
of a particular person,
they can try and pick
out facial features
by matching the images.
So it's pretty
amazing stuff, when
you think about scanning through
a crowd of hundreds of people
and being able to pick
out a specific person.
So traffic regulation, I know
that's a little less exciting.
But they take a picture of
you if you run a red light.
I've worked on a
bunch of programs
at Lincoln Laboratory
that work to look
at various aspects
of weather sensing.
I worked on one that was
made to detect lightning,
because lightning
causes forest fires.
And if you know where the
lightning is going to strike,
you can kind of be prepared.
So very specific uses
in weather sensing.
And then of course,
that brings us
to my favorite, space
exploration, which
is what I'm working on now.
So now over a broad
reach of examples,
I'm going to talk about
specifically the one for space
applications.
And this is the current
program that I'm working on.
I've been working on it
for about four years.
Right from the
very beginning when
we developed the first
prototype camera,
and we've refined it since then.
So I'll tell you
a bit about that.
Has anyone heard of it?
Because it actually has
its own Facebook page,
which is unusual
for a lab program,
because it's completely
unclassified,
and it has lots of followers.
The science community
that's looking
to use the data from TESS
is all over the world.
Like the test science
community actually
meets down the road at Harvard.
And they have people
from all over Europe.
Nobody's heard of it?
OK, so not really surprised.
But I figure Facebook, you
might have happened upon it.
So basically, the
goal for TESS--
has anyone heard of Kepler here?
So do you know what
Kepler was looking for?
AUDIENCE: Exoplanets?
KRIS CLARK: Yeah, who
knows what an exoplanet is?
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
KRIS CLARK: Exactly, sorry.
Yeah, it's any planet.
So that's a pretty large field,
because there's only nine--
I still count Pluto.
So any other planet
that you can think of
is called an exoplanet.
So something outside
of our solar system.
So Kepler did look
for exoplanets,
and it was kind of the first
one out there to look and see,
well we think there's a lot
of exoplanets out there,
but let's go look at a
specific section of the sky
and make sure, before we
build lots of other missions
to go look for exoplanets
that we're kind of right.
And Kepler did confirm there's
an awful lot of exoplanets
to look for.
So along came TESS.
TESS's goal is to go up and
spend two years basically
canvassing the
entire sky, looking
at specific types of
stars-- sort of red,
cooler stars-- to identify
where exoplanets might be.
And we do that, it's
very simple, actually.
If you have a star,
and you happen
to be looking at it when the
planet's transiting, as it's
called-- when it passes in
front of the planet-- what
do you think happens if
you're looking at a star,
and you see the
light from the star,
and the planet goes in front?
What do you think
happens to the light?
There's a shadow, right?
So the light is decreased.
And that's really the
whole principle behind TESS
is looking for those little
decreases in the light
from the star.
Now, it's got some
very specific things.
You can only see
it if the planet
is kind of orbiting
in front of the star.
If it's going around this way,
you're not going to see that.
So it's a small percentage
of chances to pick it up.
But that's how we're
going to do it.
So I have kind of a cool movie.
Let's see if I can
get this started.
They have some
really good graphics,
the people at the lab that
put this movie together.
So this is the general idea.
The planet's going
around the star.
And then at the
bottom, it'll start
to trace out the light signal.
So there's the
starlight, and then
as the planet passes in
front of it, this little dip.
Now, what do you notice when the
planet passes behind the star?
Anybody notice
anything interesting?
Like when it passes in front,
the dip is pretty obvious.
But what's the second dip?
Anybody get any ideas?
AUDIENCE: Well, I just noticed
as it goes around the star,
the line goes up a little bit.
KRIS CLARK: Yep,
so somehow we're
getting a little
more light signal.
What do you think that is?
AUDIENCE: Reflection from the
star on the on the planet?
KRIS CLARK: Exactly, exactly.
So if you think of a star
as emitting radiation
in all directions, we're seeing
the stuff coming toward us.
But as the planet
passes behind the star,
some of the light that would
be going backwards gets
reflected forwards, and then
you get this kind of increase
in your light curve.
So this is called the
characteristic light curve.
So if there were no
planet, it would just
be pretty much a constant line.
And what TESS is doing is
looking for these little blips.
And they call it
periodic, because it
happens kind of-- everyone
know what periodic means?
And the problem is,
depending on what star
you're looking at, if it's a
small planet, what do you think
happens to this if the
planet gets bigger?
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: The dip gets deeper?
KRIS CLARK: The dip get steeper.
Now, we're trying to look
for Earth-like planets.
And if you think
of Earth compared
to other planets in our solar
system, what size are we?
Like compared to
Jupiter, we're small.
So Jupiter is easy
to find, because it
reflects a lot of light,
it blocks a lot of light.
But the smaller you get, and
Earth is relatively small,
the smaller that dip is.
So TESS really needs to
detect-- it's about 1%
variation in this very
bright signal from a star.
So that's the
challenge for TESS.
Just to show you a little bit
about where TESS is orbiting--
and there's a movie, so I
won't spend too long in here--
but basically, here's Earth.
TESS goes out really far.
Like 60 Earth-radius far.
Beyond the moon.
So they call this
highly elliptical.
And that's for a lot
of different reasons,
that primarily it's a very
thermally-stable orbit,
so the temperature
stays the same.
And that's one of
many variables that go
into designing space cameras.
You have to be aware
of the environment
that your camera is
going to live in.
If you design a camera that
works in your laboratory
at like 20 degrees
Celsius or 70 Fahrenheit,
then you transcend it the
space where it's minus 80,
might not work out so well.
So some of the important
considerations.
And what TESS does is it
has two orbits per month
that it stares at a very
particular section of the sky.
And we have four
cameras aligned,
so we get a very
wide field of view.
So we kind of go like this.
There's four cameras, and
it's almost 100 degrees.
And it stares at a
section of the sky.
And then after a
month, it moves.
And basically, it scans
out the entire sky.
So TESS is going to
look at not 100%.
You can see have a few open
areas near the equator.
But about 95% of the sky,
we'll be looking and watching
for exoplanets.
So this movie shows it much
better than I can describe it.
So you can see the Moon
orbiting the Earth.
And you can see TESS goes
around the Earth twice
for every time the moon does.
And in fact, the
moon-- I don't know
a lot about orbital
mechanics, but I do
know that in the process of
getting to that final orbit,
there's about three different
orbits that it gradually
gets further and further out
till it gets that final orbit.
And it uses the moon
and gravitational pull
from the moon to hit to
get out to that last highly
elliptical orbit.
So there's a whole lot
of interesting science
just to get TESS
where it needs to go.
So now that TESS is on
its orbit, you'll watch.
And that outline
here, that's the field
of view of each of the cameras.
So there's four
cameras in a row.
And it scans out.
That's one month at a time
that it's scanning out.
Now, what do you
notice about this part?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
KRIS CLARK: Yeah.
So this is what we call the
continuous coverage zone.
So in the attempt to
see the entire sky,
there's going to
be some overlap.
So basically at the poles, we
see almost full-year coverage.
Now we're going to the
Southern hemisphere,
this is year two of the mission.
Same thing, we're going to
scan out the entire sky.
And we get almost full,
continuous coverage
at the poles.
And so not by chance,
the follow-on mission.
Has anyone heard of James
Webb Space Telescope?
It's looking up here.
So one of TESS's
goals is to provide
basically a catalog of just
thousands of places to go look.
Say, go look at
this star, we think
there's an exoplanet there.
Than James Webb
doesn't have to spend
a lot of time looking for them.
It knows exactly where to look.
And James Webb is going up
there to-- I have the picture.
It's a little bit further.
So James Webb is
going up there and is
going to have a target
planet, and go look
at the atmosphere
of that planet.
So TESS is really just
designed to find planets.
It can't really
characterize planets.
James Webb can go up and
look at the atmospherics
of the planets in
question and determine
is it really like Earth?
Is it hotter?
Is it colder?
You know, what's the atmosphere?
All right, so since you guys
have already ripped apart
cameras and are going
to be building your own,
I figured I'd show you kind of
the insides of the TESS camera.
So we identified
our two key pieces.
Now, this is basically
a section view.
So there's an awful lot of
stuff going on in there.
But basically, this whole back
end section is our detector.
This front end
section is our lens.
And anybody have any
guesses at some of the stuff
you can see in the back
behind the detector?
Anybody recognize
anything back there?
Because you're going
to see some of this
stuff a little bit later.
So detector's pretty much made
up-- you have your CCD, right?
That's your silicon active area.
But you need some electronics
behind it, too, right?
So you guys are going
to see that when you
build your Raspberry Pi camera.
You can see the electronics
that actually pull the image in,
and then you're going to
do your signal processing.
For TESS, that's all
done on this back end.
Now I am much more-- I'm
a physicist by degree,
but my whole career
has basically
been on lens design
and lens test.
So this is really
more my sweet spot.
This lens, we can characterize
it a few different ways.
So there's seven
different lenses.
So that tells you
there's an awful lot that
goes into this,
because we're looking
at a very specific band.
And so that drives how
many lenses we need
and what materials that
need to be made out of.
And we have to
match our detector.
Because if we image light
and then use a detector
that isn't very sensitive to
that particular wavelength
of light, not going to
get a very good image.
But there is one thing I
wanted to stress about TESS.
So your phone takes really
nice, clear pictures,
and you can take pictures
with your friends
and they're nice and clear.
TESS is not that kind of camera.
So if you think about
what TESS is trying to do,
it's trying to look at a
very wide field of view,
a huge area.
And does anyone
know what typically
happens when you have
a camera and you're
trying to look at a very wide
field of view with a camera?
What do you notice about
the edges of the picture?
Has anyone ever seen a very
wide field of the image?
Trying to think
of a good example.
An old school camera,
an old school photo.
The edges of the image are
not as good as the center.
So if you are trying
to optimize your camera
to look at a very specific
spot, you can do really
well in one place,
but the further
you expand your field
of view basically,
it's hard to keep the entire
field of view in focus.
And so TESS is not really
concerned about taking
really pretty, sharp images.
All it needs to
do is-- basically,
we call it a light bucket.
It's trying to collect
the light from the stars
in a small enough spot that we
can notice that little change
in the light curve.
So it's kind of a totally
different type of camera.
It's not a pretty
pictures camera.
It's a light collection camera.
And the other key
thing to think about
when you're designing
a camera, so what
are you trying to do with it?
But also, where are
you trying to do that?
So TESS is going to operate.
We design it on the ground
at a normal temperature
for you and me.
But there's a lot
of adjustments that
have to go into the
design to make sure
that when it's up in
space and really cold,
that it will
operate as intended.
So there's a lot that goes
into the camera design.
It's not just what
you're going to do,
but where you're
trying to do it.
And so this is where TESS fits
into the exoplanet puzzle.
We talked a little
bit about this before.
So I wanted to put
these pictures in,
because they look
so different, right?
So this is what
Kepler looked like.
It was looking at a very
specific section of sky.
So it was doing
something different.
It was looking at a very
narrow field of view,
and very specific planets.
TESS, you've seen
we've got four cameras.
And our goal is to just go up
there and find planets, but not
really characterize them.
And then James Webb looks
totally different than we do.
It's got multiple instruments
on the same spacecraft,
and it's going up there, and
it can actually characterize
the atmospheres of the planet.
So we get one step
closer to finding out
if there really is another
Earth-like planet up in space.
All right, so just
to kind of close out.
So we've talked about a
bunch of different cameras.
And one thing I want
to stress, they're
used in so many
different fields.
Even if you don't want to
be a camera designer, just
understanding how they work
and how different things affect
them can be useful to you in
so many different fields now.
Because even if
you're into something
that's not really
super technical,
you might end up using cameras.
And so I think no matter
what you choose to do,
it's nice to have that
ability and to really
understand how they function.
But if you do
really get into it,
there's an awful lot
of different areas
that you could
really focus on and I
think make a huge
difference in your field.
So what you can do with cameras
right now is have some fun.
So I hope you guys
have a great day,
and I hope you have fun
building the cameras
and figuring out if maybe
optical engineering or detector
or signal processing
is your passion.
So good luck with
the rest of the day.
[APPLAUSE]